everyone made it on the show for a
reason some of them I they didn't let me
know the reason the log robbery is
officially Oh Monique Hart you've got a
heart of gold
the voice of an angel and a hairline
that looks like it's been with a weed
wacker what surprised you the most about
the whole drag race experience I kind of
expected it to be something that you
can't expect you know all of the past
drag race alum their biggest advice to
me was expect the unexpected my drag mom
of sorts Sharon Needles
always has her two cents to add to
pretty much anything that I'm doing how
did that relationship come together so
I'm from Philadelphia and whenever she
would come to the city to perform and
she would always invite me over to like
her hotel room or to get dinner before
the show
I'm just so I could like hang with her
and feel cool and included we created
this friendship and bond and then once I
started getting into drag she kind of
saw something in me and and I knew that
I'd go far and got on drag race and I
think she just kind of wanted a chunk of
the $100,000 if I did get that side
greed if that's all I need to do is uh
is to it
don't need a little - ugh - a nice
charity I'm okay with that
who's laughing now who is your favorite
all-time drag race contestant beside
Sharon Needles I would have to say Raja
has definitely been a huge standout for
me and she was you know just [ __ ]
enough just friendly enough just
creative enough just funny enough I saw
winning star quality in that and well
obviously we know yeah if you could
compete against any former drag race
contestant who would you want to compete
against one of them who went home first
or something
banjee you know very grateful for this
comparison but me and milk and me and
violet get compared quite frequently for
lots of different reasons yeah so I
think just with you know how much the
fans see similarities it'd be nice to
see how we put your album together yeah
yeah that'd be cool
is there a challenge from seasons past
that you wish you could have done oh
absolutely
season six for a lot of reasons but
there was the oh no she better don't rap
challenge I always thought that would be
really fun whatever the dance challenge
in season five was that looked like a
lot of fun
and you missed Gaga by a season yeah you
bet oh wow it's tough but we're getting
close
what look what you have pulled out for
the for gaga
definitely something from Born This Way
I think that whole albums era had some
like really fun fashion maybe like a UE
mermaid look that would be okay fabulous
love to turn that out the one thing I
did know I was like well if we're doing
I'm Madonna runway again my hello - okay
never mind
yeah that's the question yep
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]